VESALAINEN, SMALL GUY ON THE ICE
OTHER THAN DANGEROUS SHOT.
IT'S BASED ON DEFLECTED, AND
THE CAROLINA HURRICANES 30
SECONDS IN HAVE THEE
SLIDES DOWN THEAND A SAVE MADE B
GETS THE SHOT AWAY THAT GOES OFF
THE STICK AND IT COMES.
DEFLECTED.
GOOD SAVE BY CONNOR MADE AS FRE.
PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS FADING AWAY
HES INTERCEPTED.
BIG SAVE BY CONNOR HELLEBUYCK OF
JARVIS, AND HELLEBUYCK WILL PIC.
SCHEIFE ICE.
COULDN'T.
CENTERED TO THE FRONT OF THE
NET.
ENDSHERE BY BLAKE
WHEELER.
>> Kevin: ONE BOBBLED PUCK AND
IT'S A TURNOVER FOR
IT WITH.
IN FOR CHATFIELD.
SAVE.
HELZ.
THEY
HACK-AND-WHACK, PUSH.
YOU CAN SEE THE REFEREE.
THIS MAY BE A SHAFT AHO'S 11TH.
FIVE OF HIS 10 GOALS IN.
>> Refere]
ONE-GAME GOAL.
2-1 CAROLINA.
>> Kevin: HE EXTENDS HETS HAVE
KNOTTED THIS GAME UP AT TWO.
>> Kevin: O COMING BETWEEN
THE LEGS AND WHAT ALL-AROUND THT
>> Dennis: PIERRE-LUC DUBOIS
STARTS WITH COPP AND CAROLINA A2
LEAD.
>> Kevin: YEAH. IT.
LOGAN STANLEY GETS THE STICK BUT
NOT ENOUGH OF IT.
CROSS THE GOAS
APPROACHING AND GET TO THE LINE.
OF